you need to be able to show people that
you can do what you say you can do and
if you're just a screenwriter then that
means writing a really kick-ass script
and putting it in front of somebody and
making the first page so good that they
have to keep reading to page five and
making the first five page is so good
they have to keep reading to page 10 and
making the first 10 page is so good that
they never put it down until they get to
the last page and they have to pick up
the phone and call you as soon as
they're done that's how good your script
has to be and it can't be that good that
you can't think it's that good all your
friends have to read it and think holy
this is the best thing I've ever
read can I say that on your you please
we're on the Internet have you please
will answer it for there okay and and
then your friends have to show it to
their friends and people who don't even
know you have to read this and think
this is the best thing I've ever read I
can't wait to see this on television or
in the movies and when you have a script
that's getting that kind of reaction
from your friends then you can walk into
somebody's door and say here this is
what I can do read this and you will
hire me and you'll have that confidence
to go into the room and exude that and
if you have that confidence people will
read that first page if you walk into
somebody's office and you feel that way
about your material and you know without
a shadow of a doubt that this is a great
script that gets across to people and
they'll read your first page but if your
first page is amateurishly written
they're going to stop right there
somebody sent me a great idea and it was
one of the few times in the last year
where somebody contacted me said hey I
have this idea for a movie I've written
a script would you read it and the the
pitch which they actually broke the
rules and they sent me the pitch in the
very first email so that I had you know
I would have had to stop reading and you
know to not have been exposed to the
idea and fortunately it was not an idea
I already had
um but it was an interesting idea and so
I said sure send me the script and you
know we did a release form and they sent
me the script and I got the script and I
was really excited to read it and the
first page I opened it up and it wasn't
even formatted properly and I read the
first page and and they weren't writing
in proper sentences and I had to slog
through this thing to figure out what
they were trying to say and I gave up
after a couple of pages because they
just they'd abused me basically they'd
stolen my time they'd wasted my time on
something that wasn't a professional
product that could never be produced in
its current state and maybe if I had
forced myself to read the whole script
there would have been a nugget in there
that was a great idea and with some work
you know I could have pounded the script
into shape and tried to do something
with it but who has that time and who
knows you could get to the end of this
hundred and twenty page script it takes
you two hours out of a very busy day and
you get to the end it could all have
been crap even even though that one
sentence pitch they sent me was a good
idea so you got to be sure and you can't
just read it yourself and think it's
great other people have to be telling
you it's great
you